Take a look at this baseball team.
They're the 2022 World Series winners.
The Houston Astros.
“...Kyle Tucker.”
“This time they finished the job!”
More than half the players
on this team
aren't from the United States.
13 of them in this photo
are from Latin America.
But one country in particular
stands out with six players
on this team...
The Dominican Republic.
In fact, a number of Dominican players
are on some of the best teams
in Major League Baseball
across the country.
Overall, they make up more than 10%
of all players in the league.
By far the most in the pool
of foreign born players.
So what's so special about baseball
in the DR?
And why do so many of its players
end up in the US?
“Yes, there's no doubt about it.”
“Baseball is king.”
Baseball has a very long history in the US.
A college student scribbled something
about playing “baste ball”
way back in 1786...
and that's considered the first mention
of the game in the country.
Over time, college campuses
became home to baseball...
while professional teams started
shaping up across many states.
By 1901, a couple of wealthy Americans
organized these teams into
two professional leagues:
the National League and the American League.
Together, they would eventually
become known as
Major League Baseball
or the MLB.
Since the 1900s, teams have been
playing against each other
until the best from each league
ends up in the World Series.
The first World Series
was a hit right away.
It brought in over 100,000 attendees...
and tens of thousands of dollars.
Over the next few years...
millions of fans bought tickets
to these games...
and baseball executives started building
massive stadiums to make
room for them.
By the early 20th century...
baseball became a very profitable industry.
And it became known as
America's favorite pastime.
But during all that time,
baseball was becoming
the favorite pastime over here
in the DR, too.
And it got there
via Cuba.
The game first arrived here
in Havana in the 1860s...
mostly through elite Cuban students
who attended college in the US...
and brought the game
back home with them.
Some of them set up teams
that started playing each other.
Eventually, the sport spread through
affluent Cubans in Havana...
to the working class
around the country.
If it’s a company...
and the owner of the company
is the one playing the game
they might encourage their workers
to play the game as well
so that a game can be played.
For the game to become
a national entity...
it has to be rooted in
the working class.
Over the years
baseball became such a big part
of the country's identity...
that Cubans took
their favorite sport
with them wherever they went.
That happened in the 1860s...
when many slaves revolted
against the wealthy...
especially sugar plantation owners
who fled in search of a new place
to set up shop.
They ended up nearby...
in the Dominican Republic.
And they brought baseball
with them.
Once again
the sport first took off with
an affluent crowd in the capital...
before taking hold over
the workers in the east...
especially the city of
San Pedro de Macorís
where Cuban ex-pats had set up
their sugar refineries.
What these refinery managers
and owners did
was they created incentives
for their workers.
Namely, that if you can beat
a nearby refinery next Saturday
well, you just don't have to work.
Games between refineries here
became huge spectacles...
and a pastime for Dominicans everywhere.
When you have the economic incentive...
wedded to a tremendous...
fan base and passion...
so that after the game, people argue
about who played what...
and who was excellent,
who wasn't
they’re creating a baseball culture.
Back in the US and Cuba
baseball continued to thrive.
Teams in the US
played more and more games
throughout the country...
making baseball a million dollar industry.
While in Cuba
it became the most popular sport
for a very different reason.
For many, many years
when Spanish colonial rulers
tried to squash Cuban identity...
including their love of baseball
Cubans pushed back.
Instead of giving up the sport...
they turned it into a symbol of
pride and nationalism.
After the Spanish-American War,
Spain left Cuba
and the US occupied the country
for four years.
That's when Americans learned more
about Cuban baseball talent...
and the MLB soon realized
they could get skilled players
on cheaper contracts than
some American players.
So they started signing Cuban players.
By the late 1950s...
the MLB had signed 49 Cubans
and players like Minnie Miñoso
and Luis Alomá had become
household names.
But after decades of US military
interventions in Cuba...
the two countries broke relations in 1961...
after the Cuban Revolution and
Fidel Castro's rise to power.
“This was the scene of turmoil
in the capital of Havana...
as the climax of revolution was reached.”
That put the MLB's entire operation at risk...
because they couldn't rely on
Cuban talent anymore.
There had to be something monumental
that broke that trend.
Once that trade embargo happened...
then that talent had to be
picked up from elsewhere
and that was an opening
for the Dominican Republic.
No question that that played a big role.
The US and the DR had a very rough
relationship at first.
In the early 20th century
The DR owed a significant
amount of money to Europe...
and that created the possibility of
a European military intervention.
But the US didn't want European forces
near its borders...
so it sent troops to occupy the DR.
The occupation was brutal
and lasted eight years.
But something unexpected happened
during the occupation.
Dominicans played baseball games
against the US troops...
and often beat them.
Many of the local players
especially around the
San Pedro Sugar Mills area...
where a lot of the fighting took place
were against the occupation.
So these games took on
a new meaning.
What is interesting is that
the game is not so much
beating the Americans...
but that as a result of
beating the Americans
they get more pride
in their own game.
By the 1930s, after the occupation ended...
Professional teams in the DR
were getting bigger.
And it became an arena
where players from the sugar mill teams...
could showcase their talents
on a national stage.
But even the best Dominican players
many of whom were of
black African descent...
didn't end up with the MLB at that time.
Because in the US, baseball leagues
were segregated.
So instead of trying
to make it in the US...
the professional league in the DR
brought over talented American baseball players
from the Negro League who were
also left out of the MLB.
Players from this league ended up
playing in the DR
during their offseasons for extra income...
like Satchel Paige
who was paid thousands of dollars
for playing on Dominican dictator
Rafael Trujillo’s
professional team.
These Dominican professional league games
drew thousands of spectators
who wanted to watch
Negro League players, as well as the
Dominican players
who are now receiving more attention.
So by the late 1950s
after the desegregation of baseball
in the US...
the MLB turned its full attention to the DR.
They found a new pipeline for talent.
It was an extension of
the neocolonial relation.
Major League Baseball was finding cheap resources...
signing it on the cheap,
taking it to elsewhere
to get refined and consumed
in another place.
By the 1960s, the MLB
was expanding quickly.
They added more teams that meant
they needed more players.
They signed outstanding Dominican players
like Ozzie Virgil
the Alou Brothers and
Juan Marichal...
who brought thousands of fans
to the MLB games.
Soon, the MLB wanted more
Dominican players...
but they quickly realized
they needed local scouts to spot talent.
That's where popular scouts like
Epy Guerrero and Ralph Avila came in.
Epy created the country's first
baseball academy in the 1970s
to train young talent.
Then in 1987, Ralph created an academy
that was directly linked to
an MLB team in the US:
the Los Angeles Dodgers.
The LA team invested millions
in this academy.
Together, they created a formal process
for Dominican players to end up
on MLB teams.
It goes something like this:
Dominican scouts identify new talent
throughout the country.
Then they hold tryouts where
players showcase their skills.
The most impressive players
get a contract to train
with the academy.
If a player makes it through training...
they either sign a professional contract
to continue training with a
minor league team in the US...
or make it to an MLB team.
Only a small percentage of the trainees
actually achieve the MLB dream.
But that's what happened with
former pitcher Ramone Martinez...
who went straight from the academy
to playing for the LA Dodgers.
“And Ramone Martinez
no hitting the Marlins
seven to nothing.”
Soon, other big teams set up academies
that help them spot
and train major players
like Robinson Canó
and Albert Pujols, who eventually
became All-Stars.
This pipeline of talent worked
so well for the MLB
that there are now 30 academies
in the DR.
One for each of the 30 MLB teams
in the US.
Since the beginning of the academy system...
the MLB has signed hundreds
of Dominican players.
And the leading cities for this talent pipeline
are the same as the ones
where the sugar mill games
were once played.
With San Pedro right at the top.
The system has created an opportunity
for top Dominican players to end up
with the MLB.
And they make millions now.
But no matter how far
the Dominican players go...
the MLB still signs them for less
than some American players.
So this is still a way for them
to make massive profits in the US
while giving foreign-born players
cheaper contracts.
The DR makes money off the academy system, too.
The scouts helped negotiate
better contracts for the players
but keep a massive cut for themselves
at every turn.
Overall, Dominican players
bring in about $400 million per year
in the Major League.
And they send about half of that home.
Plus, the academies bring in about
$125 million a year, create more jobs...
and the MLB spends millions maintaining them.
There's no question that after
agriculture and tourism
baseball has become the third leading
source of revenue
for the country as a whole.
Before the Dominican players who helped
generate so much of their profit...
the system has a long way to go.
Some Dominican All-Stars are starting
to push for that change.
They're using their fame in the MLB
to ask for a system
that works equally for players
in both countries.
To them, baseball is as much Dominican
as it is American.
They are so passionate about the game.
They have such a deep history for the game.
An understanding of the game.
They're actually in positions
of control.
So it's a battle between
who controls the game.
Hey everyone.
I'm Rajaa, the producer of
this episode of Vox Atlas.
Thank you so much for watching.
There's so much we couldn't get to
but this video is just a start.
If you want to learn more about
what players go through
in these academies...
we added a couple of great resources
in our description as well.
Our goal with Atlas and
all of our coverage
is to help you understand
the big global topics.
Which is why we want to keep
our work for free.
But advertising isn't enough
to support all the work
that goes into Atlas.
If you really like our videos,
head to Vox.com/give-now
to chip in and keep our work
free for everyone.
Once you're a contributor,
you'll get behind the scenes
emails and alerts on
how to get involved.
Thank you for watching.